hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt wir
läuten die sparte saison ein und heute
geht es bei uns ein leckeres spargel
rezept mit pelle nudeln mit rindfleisch
und ja mit spiegel und tomaten
also wir sind hier in der spargel region
und für uns gibt's auch wirklich
regelmäßig dann spiegeln meine eltern
und wir haben das auch bei uns im garten
und können es da auch selber ernten
aber wenn man nicht so viel also wir
müssen trotzdem immer ein bisschen auch
wasser zu kaufen denn wir essen wirklich
gern spielmacher das muss man schon
sagen wie es auf türkisch spargel
roskomos genau gewogen
ja das heißt auf ja- wort heute
übersetzt kommen was heißt dass er sich
nicht drauf setzt also der vogel setzt
sich nicht drauf heißt auf türkisch na
ja auf jeden fall brauchen wir an
zutaten etwas butterschmalz zum anbraten
des rindfleischs dann habe ich hier in
der hüfte steak und zwar drei stück ab
200 gramm also insgesamt 600 gramm etwas
olivenöl 500 gramm penne nudeln 2
zwiebeln 2 knoblauchzehen hier habe ich
jeweils 500 gramm grünen und weißen
spargel hier vorn habe ich 150 gramm
cocktailtomaten 150 gramm getrocknete
tomaten salz pfeffer chili und wer
möchte kann später noch ein bisschen
pinienkerne obendrauf geben
ich nehme jetzt zuerst mal das
rindersteak natürlich kann man dieses
rezept auch einfach vegetarisch machen
und das rindfleisch einfach weglassen
man kann es auch man kann auch dann
vegan machen behörden oder schmalz weg
gesetzt kann man auch machen
genau jetzt werde ich zuerst einmal das
rindfleisch anbraten
dafür nehme ich jetzt butter schmalz und
mich so als butterschmalz weil man das
ganz hoch erhitzen kann und deswegen zum
braten und frittieren denen mit der
hitze die pfanne
jetzt kann das fleisch ganz scharf
angebraten werden
jetzt gebe ich das fleisch in den
backofen es von beiden seiten jetzt
angebraten und im backofen darf noch mal
bei 70 grad ein bisschen garen sodass es
medium wird und in der zwischenzeit
bereit ich schon mal den rest vor
ich hab das fleisch ist übrigens
angebraten damit schöne röstaromen
entstehen und im backofen darf selbst
medium durchgaren also nicht durchgehen
aber medium werden damit es schön zart
wird
jetzt nehme ich den spargel und schäl
den den grünen muss man nicht schälen
den weißen schädlich jetzt komplett beim
grünen grüne nämlich nur meist gern das
untere drittel bisschen recht also ich
mag einen grünen spargel passt noch mehr
als den weißen wie kannst du richtig
toll auf dem grill legen einfach so
essen es ist dann die fleischer satz
ganz ganz lecker und einfach in der
pfanne mit bisschen olivenöl anbraten
und einfachen bürger mache so richtig
knackig ist er weiß wer wird dann eher
so lady gaga kesha lecker für dich
deswegen haben jetzt hier beides
verbunden und vor allem sieht es später
richtig hübsch aus wollten sie nicht
immer schon mal die spargelkönigin
werden in pusan immer gibt nein ich
glaube auf dem maimarkt da wird doch
irgendwie die spargelkönigin gewicht
jawohl die spargelkönigin 2010 sie
können sich alle werte spiegeln könig
bewerben
vielleicht erfährt ein zuschauer mit
abstimmen kann hat gute chancen sieht
schlecht aus
mittlerweile koch das nudelwasser jetzt
gebe ich hiermit rein
die brauchen etwa neun minuten bis er al
dente sind ich werde jetzt vier minuten
kochen und nach der hälfte der zeit
kommt nämlich der weiße spargel mit dazu
dann schneide ich jetzt aber noch kurz
klein also es können dann sich alles
auch schon vorher vorbereiten und zwar
schneide ich den so schräg in etwa zwei
bis drei zentimeter stücke die köpfe
lasse ich aber draußen spanischen
gemüse- und mit mann sagte koenigs gegen
diese reise gehen irgendwas dazu weiß
was er an ist und es auch richtig teuer
sparen lässt sich auch sehr viel arbeit
denn abzustellen einmal steht da muss ja
wirklich spaßig verschweigen abstechen
was hat sich das trio die kosten 7 euro
das wäre sogar noch ja es kommt immer
darauf an so ein mangel zeit direkt ist
ein bisschen günstiger
und wenn man natürlich schon vorher also
vor der hauptzeit bissle was möchte ist
natürlich teurer als im moment zwischen
sechs und acht ja sogar ein bisschen
mehr 13 euro daher hat jetzt wirklich 13
euro kostet bei uns im garten etwas hat
mir gegrüßt 13 euro oh mein gott laden
die freunde draußen ist dann selber
genau in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal die zwiebeln fein hacken und
zwar mache ich das feine ringe
und die knoblauchzehe schneidigen
scheiben
jetzt die zwiebeln und knoblauch
scheiben in etwas butterschmalz anbraten
und da kommt gleich dann der grüne
spargel mit dazu da wird nämlich nur
gebraten und nicht gekocht
deswegen kann ich dir jetzt auch schon
mal schneiden
jetzt kann der grüne spargel direkt nur
dazu da sind jetzt auch die weißen köpfe
mit dabei hat ein komischer die weißen
spargel kräfte und das würde zur etwa
drei vier bis fünf minuten gebraten der
grüne spargel sei ruhig noch etwas
knackig sein und in zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal die tomaten und die
getrockneten tomaten schneiden
die cocktail tomaten werden jetzt
geführt und die getrockneten tomaten
schneide ich eben schreiben
jetzt können die tomaten direkt mit dem
steigenden zwiebel dann kurz umrühren
mittlerweile sind die nudeln auch
agenten und das starke liste ein
bisschen ist es aber ich mag dazu wenn
ihr den spargel gerne etwas weise haben
wollt gibt's den spargel direkt mit dem
modeln ins nudelwasser guckt mal die
tollen farben alles wunderschön sind da
kriegt man gleich hunger auf der spirit
abschnitten typen
jetzt kommen die nudeln mit dem speichel
mit jeder 2 und jetzt vergessen vorher
etwas nudelwasser aufzufangen wollte ich
noch machen aber ich habe zehn noch ein
bisserl was drin also gebe ich in
nudelwasser mit rein
aber so eine tasse voll seine ganz große
shops schöpfkelle voll wird auf jeden
fall gut reichen jetzt alles gut
umrühren sieht in dem topf auch so schön
ausgehen
jetzt gebe ich noch ein bisschen
olivenöl mit rein und zwar für den
geschmack so wird alles gut pfeffern und
salzen und wer möchte gibt wie gesagt
noch etwas chili mit aktionen in so
besser bisher rein vegan
aber bei uns kommt noch gleich das
gleiche
so murat jetzt kann man gleich essen
gebe es hier noch ein bisschen
chiliflocken mit rein hab ich jetzt
überlegt mal die sanierer möchte sie
nicht mitessen die wir jetzt nur nudeln
und nur fleisch das noch kurz beim
national jetzt schneide ich das fleisch
in streifen erhalte ich wollte noch
wissen
und jetzt schneide ich das fleisch in
streifen wie kann man es nämlich richtig
schön zu überlegen wo ist der gigantisch
aus darüber ganz geraden stück probieren
bevor es in den bevor das günstige
flaschen den teuren spargel richtig cool
boss ist richtig sagt ich bin ja auch
vollzeitlich damit umgegangen
so jetzt habe ich hier noch ein bisschen
fleisch saftig wollte eigentlich jetzt
das fleisch ein bisschen damit
marinieren
aber wir genießen das jetzt einfach hier
noch mit rein oder das ist ein richtiges
perfektes sonntagsessen finden gefragt
aus einem topf und soweit genau bedenkt
dass er starke 13 euro kurse werden will
ich sage es auch weihnachtsmenü klappt
das leider mit der spargelsaison und der
weihnachtsmann
also ich mach das jetzt durch richtet
sie die nudeln an und ich gucke jetzt
auch das natürlich spiegeln mit dazu
bekommt hier noch ein stück und dann
bekommst du noch fleisch drüber man kann
alternativ auch riechen ja zum beispiel
und dann habe ich jetzt hier noch ein
paar pinienkerne geröstet in der pfanne
ohne fett
die kommen jetzt auch mit drüber weil es
gibt wieder noch mal zusätzlich zu dem
grünen spargel richtigen platz genau und
du darfst du schon mal ein paar sachen
drüber machen
das nächste käserei bist machst hier
drauf so drüber
sein freund vermerkt dass elektrisch
aber es ist so laut ich finde sagt
wolkow electric kool aber bitteschön
zusammenzubekommen
er hat mich gesehen von frank stocker
aber ich hab halt gedacht war ja immer
wenn ihr paris einkauf immer im abstieg
war bei den beiden
schon geriebene ist meistens trend in
mir drin hast du genau jetzt probiere
alle möchten wie es schmeckt ich weiß
ich hab das fleisch in streifen
geschnitten du kannst gerne viel kleiner
schneiden also also vom geschmack her
ist jetzt mein lieblings zutaten vom
preis her nicht jetzt wo wir schon mal
vermerk mal richtig demokratisch hatten
schwabe schwäbischer tür so echt super
also echt lecker man kann auch ohne
fleisch ist ja natürlich kann man es
auch ohne fleisch essen
also ich finds auch ohne fleisch ein
richtig tolles gericht und zeigt man die
kamera mensch die zuschauer also sage
ich gerne sehen ich will ich will ich
auf den punkt ich finde es wahnsinnig
und anzuwenden den spargel und dann die
panik dass die lustige geschmack diesen
wahnsinn verbot oder jetzt auch lust auf
die sap bekommen habt dann könnt ihr das
rezept gerne nachlesen auf meinem blog
auf salehs - blog.de das stets noch mal
ganz genau gerne durch die mir schreiben
ob jetzt nach gemacht habt es euch
schmeckt und vor allem seid ihr auch
sparten liebhaber sowie wird wenn ja
dann können wir auch gerne noch weitere
spargel rezepte machen gerne durch die
mehr auf das in die kommentare
reinschreiben sowie die gerade
zuschauern geschrieben was man mit und
spanien zb tw wer lust machen auf das
gleiche mit sauce hollandaise genau wie
man richtig tolles abwechslungsreiches
sparkonzept also viel spaß beim
nachkochen und wir lassen uns jetzt
schmecken
es sind auch eine riesenportion gerne ja
das essen sind von gästen und wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten mal bis dann zum
gesetz ja wir also bei den superpreis
möglichkeit verlangen
kriegst du alles wahr ist scharf aber
ich esse es teurer